aussitôt après lionel jospin a décidé de
poursuivre son voyage
lionel jospin qui s'était entretenue par
téléphone avec et yasser arafat qui
essaiera fat qui a fermement condamné
ces incidents
voici comment et en quels termes a réagi
le premier ministre qui me maintient
donc le programme de sa visite
officielle dans les territoires
palestiniens
j'ai vite un bear le cortège de lionel
jospin a quitté bir zeït sous les jets
de pierres et dans l'affolement général
quelques kilomètres plus loin le calme
est revenu les voitures s'arrêtent
le premier ministre tient raconté sa
version des faits les véhicules
calmement comme il convient donc voilà
il ya eu avec toi un des bars dans
l'université puis après dans ce cas là
il faut simplement aller au devant des
choses devaient accepter sereinement
il avait été blessé non non et vous
allez poursuivre votre voyage de son
jugement
valera visites continues ton assez rare
à pâte est venu personnellement
accueillir lionel jospin sont arrivés à
gaza où siège le leader palestinien
les sourires tente de faire oublier ce
qui s'est passé dans la matinée
cette fois la rencontre se déroule sous
très haute surveillance
il faut dire qu'ici contrairement à bir
zeït la police palestinienne est en
charge de la sécurité et elle a
quadrillé le terrain pour éviter tout
débordement
mais le programme de lionel jospin
comporte encore une étape à risque cet
après midi le camp de réfugiés de radio
n'est ce là bas comme à bir zeït la
petite phrase sur le hezbollah pourrait
avoir des conséquences